はい。じゃ、トレーニングお疲れ様でした。
ありがとうございました。
初めてのピラティスいかがでしたか?
きつかったけど楽しかったです。
[笑い]
良かったです。今日は、ま、姿勢を見てあまり使えていないところを使うメニューが多かったので、ま、ちょっときつかったなと思うんですけど、強度は大丈夫そうでしたか?
はい。できました。
良かったです。
じゃ、ま、実際こんな感じで今日みたいにトレーニング続けていくとどう変化が出るのかってあんまり初めてピラティスだとあんまりご存知もないかなとは思うので、ま、ちょっと分かりやすい例でちょっとご一緒説明していきますね。
はい。
はい。じゃあ実際こんな感じで分かりやすい方がこの方なんですけど、ま、見ていただくと結構分かりやすい。
うん。
うん。特にさんと同じ半身がかなりすっきり
してるのと、ま、体型の変化だけじゃなく、こう肩が前に入りやすかったのが姿勢の変化も出るぐらい
うん。
うん。ただ動かすだけじゃなくてピラティスのいいところ姿勢の綺麗なラインの変化が出てくるので感じで全身に変化が出てきます。
へえ。
あとはじゃ、続いて今後のご利用についてのお話も今日させていただいてもよろしいですか?
はい、お願いします。
はい、ありがとうございます。
は、こちらのIUでの通い方は2
パターンございまして、まず
こう短期集中プランでこう目標しっかり持っていただいてる方、あとは期間ちょっと早めに変えたいという方とかあと初めてラティスされる方はこんな感じで
1回60分でしっかり全身を使って週に
1回っていただく回数権での通い方。
あとはこちらもう1
つ定学のこうまず気軽に運動習慣をつけていきたいな方が今日ぐらいの
30分のトレーニングで週に
1回通っていただくっていうこ
2パターンでの通い方がございます。
うん。
で、原さんの場合は、ま、お悩みが全身
しっかりあるのと、あとは期間もちょっと早くな、寄中で変えていきたいということなので、ま、全身まずしっかり変えていきたいのだったらこの
16回、4
ヶ月で下半身までけて変えていく
16回見がおすめです。
うん。
ただこうまず始めるの不安だなとかまず上半身の変化を見ていきたいなっていう場合はこちらの
2ヶ月でまず上半身変化出るまでの
8回見もおすめですね。
うん。
実際この2
種類のプラン見ていただいていかがですか?
そうですね。
できるだけ早くやりたいので
そうですね。はい。16
回見かなと思います。はい。
そうですね。
せっかくなので、じゃあ全身変わるところまで頑張っていきましょうか。
はい。お願いします。
はい。かしこまりました。